Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Oil is above all a great temptation. It is the temptation of ease, wealth, strength, fortune, power. It is filthy, foul-smelling liquid that squirts obligingly up into the air and falls back to earth as a rustling shower of money. To discover and possess the source of oil, it feels as if,
感谢您收听《历史其余部分》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。石油首先是一种巨大的诱惑。它是对安逸、财富、力量、好运和权力的诱惑。它是一种污浊、恶臭的液体，会讨好地喷涌到空中，然后像一场沙沙作响的钞票雨一样落回地面。去发现并拥有石油的源头，感觉就像，
after wandering long underground, you have suddenly stumbled upon royal treasure. Not only do you become rich, but you're also visited by the mystical conviction that some higher power has looked upon you with the eye of grace and magnanimously elevated you above all others, electing you its favourite. The concept of oil expresses perfectly the eternal human dream of wealth achieved through lucky accidents, through a kiss of fortune and not by sweat, anguish, hard work. In this sense, oil is a fairy tale, and like every fairy tale, a bit of a lie. So Tom, Tom Holland, that was Ryszard Kapuscinski, the great Polish travel writer, in his brilliant book, Shah of Shars, about Mohammad Reza Pahlavi, the last shah of Iran.
在长久地在地底徘徊之后，你突然偶然发现了王室的宝藏。你不仅变得富有，而且还会产生一种神秘的信念，仿佛某种更高的力量以恩典的目光注视着你，慷慨地将你提升到所有人之上，选择你作为它的宠儿。石油的概念完美地表达了人类永恒的梦想：通过幸运的偶然、通过命运的吻而不是通过汗水、痛苦和辛勤工作来获得财富。从这个意义上说，石油是一个童话，像所有童话一样，它多少有点谎言。所以，汤姆，汤姆·霍兰，刚才那是雷沙德·卡普施辛斯基，伟大的波兰旅行文学作家，在他关于伊朗最后一任国王穆罕默德·礼萨·巴列维的精彩著作《沙阿的沙阿》中的言论。
He had a pretty catastrophic encounter with oil because it was the oil boom of the 1970s that basically brought him down. And the fascinating thing about this is that the story of oil and energy is this kind of occult history that runs in parallel with the traditional kind of political histories yeah but but they do intersect and occasionally in the traditional books oil kind of pops up but actually we don't you know we take it for granted we don't really dig into it as much as we as much as we should do the question of energy and energy dependence do we yeah you're absolutely and um a couple of months think, before Christmas, we did an episode on the old crisis of 73, 74. And one of the things that actually wasn't just the political context that made me want to do that. It was reading in manuscript a book that, well, actually, do you know, Dominic, very modestly, I'm going to read what I said about it because it's appeared on the back of the book. Regular listeners will know that Tom reading his
他遭遇了一场相当灾难性的石油碰撞，因为正是20世纪70年代的石油热潮基本上击垮了他。而这其中最引人入胜的一点是，石油和能源的故事就像是一种隐秘的历史，与传统的政治历史平行运行。是的，但它们确实会交织在一起，偶尔在传统的史书中，石油会突然出现，但实际上我们并没有——你知道的，我们认为它是理所当然的，我们并没有像我们应该做的那样去深入挖掘它，关于能源和能源依赖的问题，对吗？是的，你完全说对了。而且，呃，就在圣诞节前的几个月，我们做了一期关于73、74年石油危机的节目。其实促成那一期节目的不仅仅是政治背景。而是我读到了一份手稿，哦，其实，你知道吗，多米尼克，我非常谦虚地读一下我当时对它的评价，因为它被印在了书的封底。经常收听的听众会知道，汤姆朗读
own words is a familiar feature of this podcast. I know, shameless. But I said, to read this on the history of the past centuries, to see it in a sudden sharp definition, it is akin to looking through glass after the window cleaner has been. And that window cleaner, Dominic, was the great Helen Thompson. I'm sure she'd be delighted by that metaphor. Professor of political economy at Cambridge. She was presenter of a fabulous podcast called Talking Politics, which was actually not just the first podcast I ever listened to, but the first podcast on which I appeared.
他自己的话是这个播客的一个熟悉特色。我知道，这太厚颜无耻了。但我当时说，阅读这本关于过去几个世纪历史的书，在突然清晰的定义中看到它，就像在擦窗工来过之后透过玻璃看世界一样。而那个擦窗工，多米尼克，就是伟大的海伦·汤普森。我相信她会对这个隐喻感到高兴。剑桥大学政治经济学教授。她曾是精彩播客《谈论政治》的主持人，这实际上不仅是我听过的第一个播客，也是我作为嘉宾参加的第一个播客。
So we have Helen with us now. So I feel I'm very much returning the favor. And Helen, your book just out this week, Disorder, Hard Times in the 21st Century. I won't say you've been lucky with the timing, because obviously no one would want to see what we're seeing at the moment. But it's a book in which you cast the current crisis in Ukraine as being part of a continuum that reaches back at least a century. And essentially, your argument is, and I don't want to overly paraphrase you, but that if you want to understand geopolitics of the past century, you've got to look at oil. Absolutely. And I think that when you do, and as you've kind of suggested by comparing me to a window cleaner, when you do that, the history of the 20th century looks somewhat different. And I think it looks quite disturbing in some ways for those of us who would like to have perhaps a some what should we say a more liberal take on that history because it involves looking at some of the things that
所以现在海伦和我们在一起。所以我觉得我真是在投桃报李。海伦，你的新书本周刚出版，书名是《混乱：21世纪的艰难时期》。我不会说你在时机上很幸运，因为显然没有人愿意看到我们目前正在经历的一切。但在这本书中，你将当前的乌克兰危机视为一条可以追溯到至少一个世纪前的连续体的一部分。本质上，你的观点是——我不想过度转述你的话——如果你想理解过去一个世纪的地缘政治，你必须关注石油。完全正确。我想，当你这样做时，正如你通过将我比作擦窗工所暗示的那样，20世纪的历史看起来就有些不同了。我认为，对于我们这些可能希望对这段历史抱有某种——我们该怎么说呢——更自由主义看法的人来说，这在某些方面看起来相当令人不安，因为它涉及到审视一些
that happened in terms of the way in which the European powers who did have access to oil via their empires behaved and what the consequences of that were for other countries including what the consequences of that were most importantly for Germany. So let's go back to the very beginning of the story Helen. So oil becomes a factor in world affairs. Dominic, when you say go back to the beginning oh no come on were you were you thinking that we could get away with not mentioning the very first historian to mention oil? That's exactly what I was thinking. Do you know who that was?
通过帝国的途径获得石油的欧洲列强过去的行为方式，以及这些行为对其他国家造成的后果，其中包括对德国而言最为重要的后果。那么海伦，让我们回到这个故事的最初。石油是如何成为世界事务中的一个因素的？多米尼克，当你顺着说回到最初时，哦不，拜访吧，难道你以为我们可以避而不谈第一个提到石油的历史学家吗？我当时正是这么想的。你知道那是谁吗？
I'm going to guess it was Herodotus, Tom. It was. It was. Because Herodotus, in his great history, describes the fate of a city that was targeted by the expedition that was sent by Darius, the king of Persia, to destroy Athens, which got defeated at Marathon. But before the defeat at Marathon, they destroyed a city called Eretria. And the Eretrians got taken to a region of Iran, where Herodotus says there is a kind of black liquid, and he calls it radinarchy. It's black and it gives off a revolting stench. So the ancients were definitely aware of oil and of gas. And in fact, right at the moment,
我猜那是希罗多德，汤姆。正是如此。确实如此。因为希罗多德在他的伟大历史著作中，描述了一座城市的命运，该城市成为了波斯国王大流士派出的远征军的目标，大流士派他们去摧毁雅典，结果在马拉松战役中被击败了。但在马拉松战役失败之前，他们摧毁了一座名为埃雷特里亚的城市。埃雷特里亚人被带到了伊朗的一个地区，希罗多德说那里有一种黑色的液体，他称之为“拉迪纳奇”。它是黑色的，散发着令人作呕的恶臭。所以古代人绝对知道石油和天然气。事实上，就在此时，
I'm reading Pliny the Elder, who made this fantastic encyclopedia, absolutely panoramic. And he describes oil and the things that he says oil is good for cement and like herodotus he cites uh the walls of babylon used oil in the cement for for the great walls of babylon keeping away snakes toothache curing leprosy curing epilepsy gout and coughs so even then even in the age of pliny they knew that it was a valuable substance um and and that may be why i just actually was researching this this morning uh by going into the bodleian and i found did you did you two know that there is an oil well in new mexico called pliny the elder so i did not i did not know that either i i just throw that in because i know this
我正在阅读老普林尼的著作，他写了这部绝对包罗万象的奇妙百科全书。他描述了石油及其用途，他说石油可用于水泥，就像希罗多德一样，他提到巴比伦的城墙在建造伟大的巴比伦城墙时，水泥中使用了石油，用以驱赶蛇、治疗牙痛、麻风病、癫痫、痛风和咳嗽。所以即使在那个时候，即使在普林尼的时代，人们也知道它是一种珍贵的物质。嗯，这可能就是为什么我今天早上还在研究这个——我去了博德利图书馆，我发现，你们两个知道在新墨西哥州有一个叫老普林尼的油井吗？我不知道，我也不知道。我只是顺便提一下，因为我知道这
is going to be a very 20th century discussion but i just wanted to you know shout out for herodotus and uh and that's fair i'm sorry dominic i cut you that's all right don't worry don't worry but to be a very 20th century discussion, but I just wanted to shout out for Herodotus. That's fair enough. I'm sorry, Dominic, I cut you off. That's all right. Don't worry. But Helen, the story starts in the 19th century, doesn't it? So what are we, 1850s, 1860s, kerosene, the first oil well. So even at that point, are people conscious that this is going to mark, do you think of a geopolitical change i think at a certain point in the last third of the 19th century that in europe uh in britain and germany um and to some extent in france i think it's less well understood in in france um a terrible fear takes hold that the United States has this thing, oil, commercial drilling for oil,
将会是一场非常具有20世纪色彩的讨论，但我只是想，你知道的，向希罗多德致敬。这很公平，对不起，多米尼克，我打断你了。没关系，别担心，别担心。但这将是一场非常具有20世纪色彩的讨论，但我只是想向希罗多德致敬。这很公平。对不起，多米尼克，我打断你了。没关系。别担心。但是海伦，这个故事是从19世纪开始的，对吧？所以我们是在说1850年代、1860年代、煤油、第一口油井。那么即使在那个时候，人们是否已经意识到这将标志着地缘政治的改变呢？你认为呢？我认为在19世纪的最后三分之一的某个时候，在欧洲——英国和德国，以及在某种程度上的法国（我认为法国对此的理解不那么深入），一种可怕的恐惧开始占据上风，那就是美国拥有这种东西——石油，即商业化开采石油，
and the ability to sell this oil around the world, certainly in Europe and Asia anyway, and that this is going to have momentous consequences. I don't think that they can see the whole future of the 20th century by any stretch of the imagination. But I do think the conjunction of the united states becoming a continental state having reached the pacific plus having this new energy source that in some sense seems like miraculous particularly in its first uses in relation to to kerosene for for lighting yeah and i think in some sense it puts a fear of god into them. And I think that it's difficult in a way to understand the obsession with Africa and colonising Africa in the latter part of the 19th century by the European powers
并且有能力将这种石油销往世界各地，至少在欧洲和亚洲是这样，这将产生重大的后果。我不认为他们能够凭空想象出整个20世纪的未来。但我确实认为，美国成为一个大陆国家这一事实的结合——已经延伸到了太平洋，再加上拥有这种在某种程度上看起来像是奇迹的新能源，特别是在其最初与用于照明的煤油相关的用途上——是的，我认为在某种程度上，这让他们感到敬畏和恐惧。我认为，在19世纪后期，如果不看到欧洲列强认为这是他们的潜能、是他们试图赶超美国、与美国竞争的机会，是欧洲通往资源丰富腹地的方式——正如拥有石油的美国本土对美国而言所证明的那样——就很难理解欧洲列强对非洲的痴迷和对非洲的殖民。
without seeing that they think that this is their potential, this is their opportunity to try to catch up with the United States, to compete with the United States, that this might be the resource-rich hinterland for Europe in the way in which the continent of the United States with this oil is proof for the United States. Yeah, because you've got, what, Standard Oil in the 1870s, John D. Rockefeller's company, and using kerosene in sort of lighting and stuff. So that's precisely the point, isn't it, where the United States is coming out of the American Civil War, sort of industrially, economically, it's catching up and then overhauling Britain.
是的，因为你有，比如18世纪70年代的标准石油公司，约翰·D·洛克菲勒的公司，并将煤油用于照明之类的东西。所以这正是关键所在，对吧？美国正从美国内战中走出来，在工业上、经济上，它正在赶超并随后超越英国。
So the sort of the scramble for Africa and all that sort of colonial anxiety that you get at the end of the 19th century, do you think there's a sort of sense of technological and economic change underpinning a lot of that then? At least I think it's a sense of technological economic fear and I think that in some sense it simply is perhaps even actually more understood on the straightforward resource question rather than necessarily a technology question at that point. I think when it becomes a technology question is really when the United States goes down the road thanks to Henry Ford of mass car production. And Helen, does mass car production happen because America has the oil? I mean, is it as kind of basic as that? It's a more complicated question because actually Henry Ford's model T cars,
所以19世纪末期那种对非洲的争夺以及所有诸如此类的殖民焦虑，你认为这背后是否蕴含着一种技术和经济变革的意识呢？至少我认为这是一种技术和经济恐惧的意识，而且我认为在某种程度上，在那个时候，人们甚至可能在简单的资源问题上比在技术问题上理解得更多。我认为当它真正变成一个技术问题时，是在美国由于亨利·福特的推动而走上汽车大规模生产的道路之后。海伦，汽车的大规模生产是因为美国拥有石油吗？我的意思是，事情有这么基础吗？这是一个更复杂的问题，因为实际上亨利·福特的T型车，
they don't necessarily have to run on oil. It's a choice. He creates them in ways, he constructs them in ways where that where where where they could um they basically could run on alcohol alcohol fuel so in a sense it's a kind of darwinian test for for it in which oil proves itself oil proves itself and and and what we see with the the production of the mass production of the car is that really, I think, changes the whole nature of industrial production in the United States and those huge Ford factories that are created in Michigan. So what starts off, I think, as a resource fear in Europe
它们不一定非要靠石油运行。这是一个选择。他制造它们的方式、他构建它们的方式，使得它们基本上可以靠酒精燃料运行。所以从某种意义上说，这是对石油的一种达尔文式的考验，在考验中石油证明了自己，石油证明了自己。我们通过汽车的大规模生产看到的是，这真的改变了美国工业生产的整个性质，以及在密歇根州建立的那些巨大的福特工厂。所以，我认为最初在欧洲表现为一种资源恐惧的东西，
becomes a sense of fear that actually the United States has made this huge technological breakthrough and it's just going to leave everybody behind unless they do something to change their relationship to this energy source. Right. And so that means that European powers need, you know, they've looked to Africa, but of course the place, as people have known since at least the time of Herodotus, where oil is literally bubbling up out of the ground is the Middle East. And in the build up to the First World War, you have this very, very intense competition between Britain and Germany for kind of control of this region, or at least to influence this region. And I guess that you could say that that as much as anything is a portent of what is going to happen for the century and more that's going to follow uh very much so i mean they first start looking for uh oil in persia in i think it's 19 1901 and the first is that the british yeah first significant discovery is in in 1908 and
变成了一种恐惧感，即美国实际上已经取得了这一巨大的技术突破，除非他们采取行动改变与这种能源的关系，否则它将把所有人远远甩在身后。没错。这意味着欧洲列强需要——你看，他们曾寄希望于非洲，但正如人们至少自希罗多德时代以来就知道的那样，石油真正从地下直冒泡的地方是中东。在第一次世界大战爆发前夕，英国和德国之间为争夺该地区的控制权，或者至少是为了对该地区施加影响，展开了非常非常激烈的竞争。我想你可以说，这在很大程度上预示了随后的一个世纪及更长时间里将要发生的事情。确实如此。我的意思是，他们最早开始在波斯寻找石油是在，我想是1901年，而第一次重大发现是在1908年。
obviously britain is in a much stronger position in persia than than than germany um is and there's a considerable hope by this point there's going to be oil in Mesopotamia too, because of it being in Persia. And I think that what you can then see through the immediate years leading up to the First World War is that the British and the Germans competing to see who can have the foothold that is going to control those resources, the foothold in the Middle East to control those resources in the future. Britain's obviously in a stronger position, but the Kaiser goes a long way in developing a relationship with the Ottoman Empire that goes back really to the 1890s.
显然，英国在波斯的地位比德国要强大得多。到这个时候，人们抱有相当大的希望，认为美索不达米亚也会有石油，因为波斯有石油。我想，你可以从紧邻第一次世界大战爆发前的几年里看到，英国和德国在竞争，看谁能抢占先机去控制这些资源，在未来控制中东的这些资源。英国显然处于更有利的地位，但德皇在发展与奥斯曼帝国的关系方面走了很长一段路，这种关系实际上可以追溯到19世纪90年代。
And he physically goes there, doesn't he? I mean, he goes on kind of trips around the Ottoman province. There's a whole Berlin-Baghdad railway. Absolutely, yeah. And I mean, because they want the building, the railway in part because they want the Deutsche Bank, the big German bank is an important part of that story. And they have a concession to look for oil
而且他亲自去过那里，不是吗？我的意思是，他去奥斯曼帝国的各个省份进行了各种旅行。还有一条贯穿柏林到巴格达的铁路。完全是的。我的意思是，因为他们希望修建这条铁路，部分原因是因为他们想要德意志银行，这家德国大银行是这个故事的重要组成部分。他们本质上获得了在铁路旁寻找石油的特许权。
by the side of the railway, essentially. And that is why the Kaiser is keen on also bringing the Ottomans into the First World War. That's a central relationship for the Kaiser's keen on also bringing the Ottomans into the First World War. That's a central relationship for the Kaiser's idea of Germany's future, is that the Ottoman Empire is the route to Germany having an energy resource empire. Just on this question of the build-up to the First World War, I mean, one thing that I hadn't really, well, in the public imagination, certainly in Britain, when we think of oil, we think of America and we think of the Middle East.
这就是为什么德皇热衷于将奥斯曼帝国拉入第一次世界大战的原因。这是德皇关于德国未来构想的核心关系，即奥斯曼帝国是德国通往能源资源帝国之路。仅就一战前夕这个问题而言，我的意思是，有一件事我以前并不太清楚——在公众的想象中，尤其是在英国，当我们想到石油时，我们会想到美国，我们会想到中东。
But actually, we don't think about the place that was America's great rival as an oil producer before the First World War, which is Russia, which obviously, I mean, Russia and energy could hardly be more timely. So am I right in thinking that at the very beginning of the 20th century, so literally as we enter the 20th century, Russia is actually the world's biggest ore producer because of its ownership of what's now as by john baku yeah this this uh oil in in baku is very important it's going to play a like a crucial role in the in the story um of the first half of the 20th century um and we can actually there was just to go back to the point that tom might um is there was knowledge there was oil in Baku and some uses being made of it back to the 9th century. But serious drilling then taking place in the latter third of the 19th century. from the Ottomans, then they have a way of getting that oil from Baku to out into the Balat Sea and into the Mediterranean. And that is crucial for their ability to sell oil in the Asian market. So what you see is in the early part of the 20th century, the very first few years, is
但实际上，我们并没有想到那个在一战前作为石油生产国是美国最大对手的地方，那就是俄罗斯。显然，俄罗斯和能源这两个词放在一起再合时宜不过了。所以我的理解对吗：在20世纪的极早期，也就是我们真正进入20世纪的时候，由于拥有现在被称为巴库的地区，俄罗斯实际上是世界上最大的石油生产国？是的，这个位于巴库的石油非常重要，它将在20世纪上半叶的故事中扮演关键角色。而且我们实际上可以——回到汤姆可能提到的那一点，早在9世纪，人们就知道巴库有石油并开始了一些利用。但真正严肃的钻探发生在19世纪的最后三分之一。从奥斯曼帝国那里获得控制权后，他们就有办法将巴库的石油运送到波罗的海和地中海。这对于他们在亚洲市场销售石油的能力至关重要。所以在20世纪初，最初的几年里，
a really clear competition between the Russian companies and Standard Oil, the big American company, as to who can sell oil most effectively, successfully, both in Europe and in Asia. And for a while, the Russian companies are at an advantage, and partly they're at an advantage, obviously, because of the geographical position of Russia in relation to these markets, compared to the United States. But the political situation in Russia deteriorates very considerably, particularly in the context of Russia's defeat in the war with Japan in 1905 and in this great labor struggle that goes on in Baku, which Stalin was himself involved in as a trade union organizer.
俄罗斯公司与美国大公司标准石油公司之间展开了非常明确的竞争，看谁能最有效、最成功地在欧洲和亚洲销售石油。有一段时间，俄罗斯公司占据了优势，部分原因显然是因为俄罗斯相对于这些市场与美国相比具有地理优势。但俄罗斯的政治局势急剧恶化，特别是在俄罗斯在1905年对日战争中战败的背景下，以及在巴库发生的这场伟大的劳工斗争中，斯大林本人作为工会组织者也参与其中。
Essentially, a lot of the oil wells in Baku get burned. And so in that period, then Russian, between 1905 and 1914, then Russian oil production falls off somewhat. But already, so beginning of the 20th century, you'd look at geopolitics, and you'd say, you know, the European powers remain what they've been for at least a century, perhaps two centuries, the great controllers of Eurasia. They are the dominant powers in Eurasia. But already you can see the lineaments evolving where actually the European powers are going to be squeezed by America and by Russia. And I hadn't realized until I read your book, just how fundamental the fact that those two powers have oil actually was. And Dominic said that, in a way, it's a kind of a cult history, that once you realize the role that oil is playing, you start to see all kinds of
本质上，巴库的许多油井被烧毁了。所以在那个时期，即1905年到1914年之间，俄罗斯的石油产量有所下降。但即便如此，在20世纪初，如果你审视地缘政治，你会说，欧洲列强仍然像它们至少一个世纪、甚至两个世纪以来那样，是欧亚大陆的伟大控制者。它们是欧亚大陆的主导力量。但你已经可以看到各种轮廓正在演变，即欧洲列强实际上将遭到美国和俄罗斯的挤压。在阅读你的书之前，我并没有意识到这两大国拥有石油这一事实是多么具有根本性。多米尼克说，从某种程度上讲，这是一段隐秘的历史，一旦你意识到石油所扮演的角色，你就会以一种新的方式看待各种各样的
events and perhaps particularly conflicts in a new manner. So the First World War, could you describe the First World War? I mean, would it be feasible to describe the First World War as a war over oil? Would that be going too far? I wouldn't certainly. I certainly don't think you can give an account of the reasons why the First World War breaks out when it does in the summer of 1914, after the crisis generated by Franz Ferdinand's assassination in Sarajevo, which makes oil fundamental to the motives of the players. I think that is it. I don't really buy that. I think what is important to understand about the First World War is that we in this country, and I certainly, until I really started thinking about oil, in fact, I would say until I actually started writing the first geopolitical chapter of Disorder, kind of, I think, are accustomed in Britain and perhaps in France,
事件，或许特别是冲突。那么第一次世界大战，你能描述一下第一次世界大战吗？我的意思是，把第一次世界大战描述为一场争夺石油的战争是否可行？这会不会太过分了？我当然不会这么认为。我当然不认为你可以把1914年夏天第一次世界大战爆发的原因归结为石油，在萨拉热窝斐迪南大公遇刺引发危机之后，石油成了各方动机的根本。我认为不是这样的。我并不买账。我认为关于第一次世界大战，我们需要理解的重要一点是，我们这个国家的人，我当然也是，直到我真正开始思考石油——事实上，我可以说是直到我真正开始动笔写《混乱》的第一章地缘政治时——在英国和法国，可能就像我说的，在德国也是如此，我们习惯于通过西线战场来思考第一次世界大战，而不是从东线战场的角度去思考它。我认为一旦战争爆发，无论是英国还是德国，都有一种强烈的感觉，即利益攸关的是奥斯曼帝国的未来以及奥斯曼帝国控制领土的未来。在这种背景下，他们在战争的最初几周都采取了行动。在这方面，第一次世界大战的地缘政治有一个巨大的讽刺，一方面，
just like I said, maybe in Germany, too, to thinking about the First World War through the Western Front, and not to think about it in terms of the war in the East. And I think that once the war has begun, both in the case of Britain and Germany, there is a strong sense of that the stakes are the future of the Ottoman Empire and the future of the territory that the Ottoman Empire controls. And they both make moves in the very early weeks of the war in that context. And the great irony of the First World War in this respect, in its geopolitics, is on the one hand,
这使得英国和法国作为获胜的两个欧洲列国，在财政上完全受制于美国，并大大削弱了它们的行动自由。另一方面，它们从一战中获得了相当丰厚的回报，那就是在中东获得了一席之地，特别对英国而言，这比一战爆发前它在中东的地位要强大得多。而美国则被排除在外。因为它们当时没有对奥斯曼帝国宣战，不是吗？
it renders Britain and France as the two victorious European powers, completely financially beholden to the United States and significantly reduces their freedom of manoeuvre. On the other hand, they get something pretty significant out of the First World War, which is a position in the Middle East, particularly in Britain's case, much stronger than it had been its position in the Middle East before the First World War had begun. And the Americans are shut out of it. Because they hadn't declared war on the Ottomans, had they?
是的，美国人供应了盟军在战争期间使用的大部分石油，达到了80%。到1919年，美国不得不进口石油。美国总统伍德罗·威尔逊非常关心石油，以及美国石油供应的长期前景。而当时有英国和法国这两个国家，它们本质上在中东为自己夺取了一个帝国，那里有发现更多石油的巨大前景。将话题引向中东，引发了我们的一位听众提出的一个问题，
Yeah, Americans have supplied 80% of the oil that the Allies have used during the course of the war. By 1919, the United States is having to import oil. President Woodrow Wilson is really concerned about oil, the long-term prospects for American oil supply. And there are these two countries, Britain and France, having acquired themselves essentially an empire in the Middle East where there were great prospects for more oil to be found. Bringing us to the Middle East raises a question from one of our listeners,
他叫亚历山大·库泽尔。他说——我认为这真是一个极好的问题——如果没有石油，中东会不会只是欧洲和亚洲一个无足轻重的偏远角落，基本上不受欧洲列强的影响？显然，直到这个时候，中东——当然还有阿拉伯地区——在英国殖民者的想象中扮演的角色微乎其微。但在此之后，它的重要性变得越来越大。所以石油大概从根本上重塑了欧洲列强对中东的态度。事实上，如果我们暂时沉浸在反事实的假设中，如果没有石油，我们还会对它有一点点在意吗？关于石油和西方在中东政策的阴谋论，它们是对的吗？
Alexander Kuzel. And he says, and I think it's a great question, actually, without oil, without oil, would the Middle East be just a curious backwater of Europe and Asia, mostly untouched by the European powers? And obviously, until this point, the Middle East be just a curious backwater of Europe and Asia, mostly untouched by the European powers? And obviously, until this point, the Middle East, well, certainly Arabia, plays very little part, you could argue, in the sort of British colonial imagination. But afterwards, it becomes greater and greater and greater. So oil presumably fundamentally reshapes the attitude that the European powers have to the Middle East. And actually, just to indulge the counterfactual for a moment, would we care about it at all if it weren't for oil? Are the conspiracy theories about oil and Western policy in the Middle East, are they right?
我认为英国在石油出现之前就已经在意中东了。在这些发现之前，他们特别在意波斯湾。我的意思是，在中东任何地方发现石油之前，也就是1908年之前。为了确保通往印度的交通线。为了印度。我认为英国最初对中东的兴趣确实与保护通往印度的路线有关，然后一旦1908年在波斯发现了石油，英国认为这是他们能够与美国竞争、或者至少在石油正在创造的地缘政治世界中不输给美国的方式，石油的利益就随之而来了。如果我们接着说——我不是说我们应该直接跳到二战之后，但作为对你问题的回答，
I think that the British did care about the Middle East before oil came along. They cared about the Persian Gulf in particular before those. I mean, before there's any oil found anywhere in the Middle East, so before 1908. Securing links to India. Because of India. And I think that the initial British interest in the Middle East really comes in relation to protecting the roots to India and then the oil interest comes once oil was discovered in Persia in 1908 and the British thinking that this is the way in which that they can compete or at least not lose to the United States and in the geopolitical world that oil is um creating and if you then say we i'm not saying we should straightforwardly skip until after the second world war but just
多米尼克，一旦英国撤出印度——也就是1947年之后，我认为可以说除了对石油的兴趣以及后来的天然气兴趣之外，那里就没有发生过太多其他事情了。海伦，我说的对吗？将近东在英国和法国之间划分开来的赛克斯-皮科线，英国人对这条原本是直线的边界进行了一些调整，以确保他们能够获得摩苏尔及其周围所有的油田？是的，我的意思是，关于这一点，我认为它被夸大了，因为在那时，关于谁将控制奥斯曼帝国——也就是曾经的奥斯曼帝国——的竞争根本还没有解决。
as an answer to your question um dominate once the british are out of india so after 1947 i think it's reasonable to say that there's not much else going on but an interest in in oil and then later in gas because helen am i right that the sykes-Picot line, which divides up the Near East between Britain and France, that the British kind of adjust this otherwise straight line to ensure that they get Mosul and all the oil fields around it? Yeah, I mean, the thing about that, though, I think it's overdone because at that point is the contest for who's going to control the Ottoman, what has been the Ottoman Empire hasn't at all been resolved.
实际上，英国在1918年后期曾希望得到更多，包括对达达尼尔海峡的控制。这意味着其中真正关键的转折点在于，土耳其一旦作为独立国家建立起来，就能够比1916年所想象的更显著地维护自身利益，从而为自己保留一部分。这让我感到相当惊讶，我想可能也是在1918年，苏联在革命前后失去了对巴库的控制，但实际上它又重新恢复了对巴库的控制。所以有一个阶段，奥斯曼人、德国人和英国人基本上都
And actually, the British in the latter part of 1918 have got hopes of getting much more than that, including control of the Dardanelles. And that means that the really crucial juncture in this is the fact that Turkey, once Turkey is created as an independent state, is able to assert itself more significantly than might have been imagined back in 1916, to hold on to some of this for itself. which is quite a surprise I think it may be again in 1918 is is that the Soviet Union which loses control of Baku in the aftermath of the around the time of the revolution anyway actually reestablishes control over Baku so there's a point in which all of the essentially the Ott Ottomans, the Germans and the British
抱着控制巴库的希望，但实际上是苏联人结束了那个时期，比如说到了1923年，随着与土耳其达成协议——这可以说是关于这一切争斗的最终结束。在那些年里，是苏联人守住了它。我正想说，如果我们把时间快进到二战。我的意思是，二战并不是一场我可以说完全关于石油的战争，但石油开始发挥极其重要的作用。我的意思是，如果你对二战有所了解，人们总是把石油和两件事联系起来：第一，石油使得纳粹
have got hopes of controlling Baku, but actually it's the Soviets that end that period, let's say by 1923, by the time of the agreement with Turkey, which you might say is the final end of fighting over all this. In those years, it's the Soviets that are going to keep it. I was going to say, if we fast forward then to World War II. So i mean world war ii is not a war i would say tom about oil but oil comes to play an enormous part i mean the two so the two things that if you know a little bit about the second world war the two things that people always think about all are one the oil makes the nazis
陷入了进攻俄罗斯和高加索地区的恐怖陷阱，因为他们极度渴望得到石油。第二，石油也在日本闪击东南亚以及他们孤注一掷在珍珠港击溃美国人等一系列事件中发挥了作用。这些，它们不完全是都市传说，大概只是老生常谈吧？海伦，你认为这两点都是真的吗？
draws the nazis into this terrible trap of going for Russia and the Caucasus because they're desperate to get the oil. And two, that oil also plays a part in Japan's sort of dash to Southeast Asia and their desperation to knock out the Americans at Pearl Harbor and all of that sort of thing. Are those sort of, and they're not quite urban myths, they're just sort of commonplaces, I suppose. Are those both true, Helen, would you say?
是的，我的意思是，我认为很难低估希特勒对石油的痴迷。我的意思是，他对此着迷，你知道的，早在20世纪20年代，他就对德克萨斯油田发生的事情着迷。显然，他几乎知道德克萨斯油田所有油田的名字，显然，就像他知道美国西部几乎所有油田的名字一样，他有一种想法，
Yeah, I mean, I think that it's hard to underestimate Hitler's obsession with oil. I mean, he's obsessed with it, you know, like back in the 1920s, he's obsessed about what's going on in the Texan oil fields. Apparently, he knew about the names of pretty much all the oil fields in the texan oil fields apparently like he knew about the names of pretty much all the all the oil fields in the um american um west and he has this idea um that unless the the germany takes back who that the war's over and in some sense he's not wrong well yeah i mean you amazing comment that oil weakness was a near sufficient motive for the invasion about but at the same time dominic
即除非德国夺回巴库，否则战争就结束了。从某种意义上说，他并没有错。好吧，我的意思是，这是一个惊人的评论，即石油匮乏几乎是入侵的充分动机。但与此同时，多米尼克说这是一个可怕的陷阱，因为它是必需的，而且是完全具有破坏性的，因为在与苏联打仗时，为了做到这一点，它实际上意味着什么。所以从某种程度上说，多米尼克在开头讲述的那个故事——石油，你知道的，它是这种巨大的诱惑，如果成功了，从某种意义上说，它带来的回报超乎人们的想象。另一方面，当对它的追求出错时，它会带来可怕的毁灭。石油是否放大了自拿破仑战争以来英国战略的有效性，即利用海军力量本质上扼杀大陆竞争对手？是的，我的意思是，关于海军安全或出于能源安全目的使用海军的问题，显然是这个故事的一部分。
says it's a terrible trap because it's necessary and it's entirely destructive because of what it actually means in fighting a war with the soviet union to to do that so it is that story in a way that dominic's telling the beginning of like oil you know it's this it's this huge temptation and if it's successful then in one sense it brings rewards beyond people's imagination. On the other hand, it can bring it brings terrible destruction when the pursuit of it goes wrong. Is it the case that oil amplifies the effectiveness of what is, you know, since the time the Napoleonic Wars has been British strategy, which is to use naval power essentially to throttle continental rivals. Yeah, I mean, this question about the naval security or using navies for energy security purposes is obviously part of the story.
在二战后的世界中，将要发生的一部分事情是，在西方国家中，谁将为最初来自中东的西欧石油进口提供海军安全，然后在20世纪70年代，谁又将为来自中东的美国石油进口提供海军安全。从这个角度来看，为什么大英帝国在战后世界中仍然是必要的，正是因为不仅英国人想要、而且美国人在某种程度上实际要求的答案是，英国将成为中东的海军力量，来承担这项任务。而在战后的最初几年，美国人并不想为了这个目的使用他们的海军
And part of what is going to go on in the post-Second World War world is the question of who is going to provide of the western countries who is going to provide that naval security for initially west european oil imports out of the middle east and then what are going to become american oil imports out of the middle east in the in the 1970s and the reason why you know the british empire from this point of view is still necessary uh in the post-war world is precisely because the answer that not only the british want but the americans actually in some sense demand is is that britain is going to be the naval power uh in the in the middle east that is going to that is going to do this and where the americans don't want to use their naval
霸权。事实上，你可以争辩说，直到20世纪90年代第一次海湾战争爆发之前，他们其实并不真的想使用它。我的意思是，这让我觉得非常震撼。同样，我以前也没有充分认识到苏伊士运河危机的矛盾性质。苏伊士运河危机之所以著名，是因为它是一个美国利用其金融实力基本上削弱英国帝国努力的例子，与此同时，美国又希望英国继续充当海伦，中东石油供应的某种担保人。我想我们应该在这个时候休息一下，也许我们在休息之后可以看看这显然是战后历史中绝对关键的发展。
supremacy for this purpose in the immediate years after the war. In fact, you could argue that they don't really want to use it until the 1990s, once we get to the first Gulf War. I mean, I thought that was really striking. And again, I hadn't properly appreciated the paradoxical quality of the Suez Crisis, which is, of course, famous as an example of America using its financial muscle essentially to kind of cripple British imperial efforts while simultaneously wanting Britain to continue as a kind of guarantor of oil supplies in the Middle East. I think we should take a break at this point and perhaps we could look at this kind of what's obviously an absolutely key
EPISODE ENDING.
development in postal history after the break. episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking oil and we are exploring the question of how important a role has it played in geopolitics over the past century and more. And Helen, we have reached the post-war world, as we were talking before the break. This is a world where America and the Soviet Union, both of them great oil powers, have a preponderant role to play in world politics, but where the role of the old European emp empires and perhaps particularly the british empire is not completely gone um so how important is is the role that oil plays in the retreat from empire both not just for britain but also perhaps for france as well well i think the the first thing to say here is that actually you know britain's empire at the point in which it's falling away elsewhere,
欢迎回到《历史其余部分》。我们正在讨论石油，并探讨它在过去一个世纪及更长时间里在地缘政治中发挥了多么重要的作用。海伦，正如我们在中场休息前谈到的那样，我们已经来到了战后世界。这是一个美国和苏联——这两个都是伟大的石油大国——在世界政治中发挥主要作用的世界，但在这个世界中，老牌欧洲帝国、或许特别是大英帝国的作用并没有完全消失。那么，在从帝国撤退的过程中，石油所扮演的角色有多重要？这不仅对英国，或许对法国也是如此？嗯，这里要说的第一件事实际上是，你知道的，大英帝国在其开始在其他地方衰落的节点上——显然最深刻的影响是撤出印度以及印度的独立——在某种程度上开始变得比以前更加重要。这是因为现在整个西欧几乎都依赖来自中东的石油供应。这些石油一部分通过通往地中海的管道输送，但很大一部分是通过苏伊士运河北上进入地中海的。从某种程度上说，应该负责保持苏伊士运河畅通、并应对各种阿拉伯国家的不稳定政局对运河畅通性可能构成的任何威胁的力量，就是英国和美国。正如我所说，美国根本不想扮演这个角色。因此，一方面，从二战后的第一天起，美国人就非常热衷于将英国表现为帝国主义者和讨厌的帝国主义者，并宣称美国站在民族解放和后殖民地自我决定等一边；但他们非常希望英国继续扮演它一直在扮演的帝国角色，尽管在通往苏伊士运河危机的各个节点上，美国在军事基地方面给英国制造了相当大的困难，阻碍了英国保护苏伊士运河阵地。
and obviously most consequentially the withdrawal from India and India's independence, it's about in some sense to start to matter even more than it had previously done. It's because now the whole of Western Europe is pretty much dependent on the supply of oil from the Middle East. That is coming in part through a pipeline out into the Mediterranean, but a lot of it is coming up the Suez Canal and out into the Mediterranean that way. And in some sense, the power that's supposed to take responsibility for keeping the Suez Canal open and for dealing with whatever threats to the openness of the canal there may be arising from
你是说他们是十足的伪君子？海伦，你是这个意思吗？是的，我认为他们是。我恐怕我确实认为他们在这件事上是十足的伪君子。我的意思是，我并不是说他们处境不艰难，因为一方面——让我们退一步说——显然二战后中东的政治也因以色列作为一个独立国家的建立而变得极其复杂。因此，美国既致力于以色列，但也希望被视为对阿拉伯民族主义同情。他们在这些问题之间艰难周旋的方式是显而易见的。不那么明显、潜藏在水面之下的是他们对待英国的方式，即我们需要你们做事情，我们需要你们待在那里，但我们不希望你们表现得太像一个古老陈旧的帝国强权，从而让我们感到尴尬。
instability in various Arab countries and politics is Britain and the United States as I said simply does not want to play that role so on the one hand the Americans right from the start in the in the in the post-second world war world are very keen to present the British as imperialist and nasty imperialists and that America is on the side of you know like national liberation and post-colonial self-determination etc but they very much want the British to be playing the imperial role that it's doing even though at various points leading up to the Suez crisis they make things pretty difficult for Britain in terms of its where for Britain in terms of where its military, in terms of where its military bases are in order to protect the position at Suez.
海伦，苏伊士运河危机最迷人的地方之一——我们收到了来自王位觊觎者十四世阿方索的一个问题。他实际上发来了18个问题。我们不会全部提问。但他提出了一个对某些人来说可能与苏伊士运河没有联系的问题，但我对你在书中建立的联系着迷不已。他的问题是：欧佩克是如何被允许成立的？如果我没理解错的话，在苏伊士运河危机之后，
So are you saying they're massive hypocrites? Is that what you're saying, Helen? Yeah, I think that they are. I'm afraid I do think that they are massive hypocrites about this. I mean, I'm not saying for a moment that it's not a, it's a pretty difficult position that they're all in, because on the one hand is that, well, let's go back one step, is obviously the post-war, second world war politics
西欧国家对替代石油来源产生了更大的兴趣。其中一些国家开始将目光投向苏联。你开始看到苏联对西欧的大规模石油出口。然后美国的生产商为了与之竞争而降低了价格。这激怒了委内瑞拉的阿拉伯石油生产国。然后他们成立了欧佩克。我理解得对吗？
of the Middle East has been also hugely complicated by the creation of Israel as an independent state. So the Americans are committed to Israel, but they also want to be seen as sympathetic to Arab nationalism. And it's quite obvious the ways in which they try to navigate between those problems. What's less obvious and goes on below the surface is the way that they deal with the British, which is we need you to do things, we need you to be there, but we don't want you to embarrass us by looking too much like an old archaic imperial power.
中东局势因以色列作为独立国家的建立而变得极其复杂。因此，美国人既承诺支持以色列，又希望表现出对阿拉伯民族主义的同情。他们试图在这些问题之间寻找平衡的方式是显而易见的。而不那么明显、在水面之下进行的，是他们与英国人打交道的方式，即：我们需要你们做事，我们需要你们留在那儿，但我们不希望你们表现得太像一个陈旧过时的帝国主义大国，从而让我们感到尴尬。
One of the fascinating things about the Suez Crisis, Helen, so we have a question from Alfonso XIV, the pretender. He actually sent in 18 questions. We're not going to ask them all. But he asked a question that might not seem to some people connected to Suez, but I was fascinated by the connections that you draw in the book. So his question was, how did OPEC, how was OPEC allowed to happen? And if I understand it right, in the aftermath of the Suez crisis,
海伦，苏伊士运河危机最迷人的地方之一——我们有一个来自王位觊觎者阿方索十四世的问题。他实际上发来了18个问题。我们不会全部问。但他提出了一个对某些人来说可能与苏伊士运河无关的问题，但我对你在书中建立的联系很感兴趣。所以他的问题是，欧佩克是如何成立的？如果我没理解错的话，在苏伊士运河危机之后，
the Western European countries become much more interested in alternative sources of oil. And some of them start looking to the Soviet Union. And you start getting Soviet oil exports in a much bigger way to Western Europe. Then the American producers to compete with that drop their prices. And that outrages the Arab oil producers in Venezuela. And they then set up OPEC. Have I got that right?
西欧国家对替代石油来源变得更加感兴趣。其中一些国家开始将目光投向苏联。你开始看到苏联向西欧大量出口石油。然后，为了与之竞争，美国生产商降低了价格。这激怒了委内瑞拉的阿拉伯石油生产商。随后他们成立了欧佩克。我理解得对吗？
Just explain what OPEC is for people who may not know what that is. So OPEC is the cartel, basically the cartel, the association of major oil-producing countries. So, Helen, is that right? Is OPEC basically a consequence of the interaction between Suez and the Cold War, I guess? In the short term, I think, yeah, it very much is so. It's because what will become the OPEC members, those oil producing countries, are so aghast when the big the oil majors cut prices to European markets because they've now got to compete with Soviet oil. That those oil producing countries say, well, we don't like the way that this works we want more
简单解释一下欧佩克是什么，特别是对于可能不知道的人。所以欧佩克是一个卡特尔，基本上就是卡特尔，主要石油生产国的协会。海伦，这样对吗？欧佩克基本上可以说是苏伊士运河危机和冷战相互作用的结果吗？我想从短期来看，是的，很大程度上确实如此。因为后来成为欧佩克成员国的那些产油国，当看到国际石油巨头为了与苏联石油竞争而大幅削减欧洲市场的油价时，感到无比震惊。这些产油国便表示，我们不喜欢这种运作方式，我们想要获得更多
say in in in prices now i think you could argue that energy nationalism was on the rise that energy nationalism in oil producing countries particularly in the middle east because you can see it actually in mexico going back to 1911 and the Mexican Revolution. As the British Empire in the Middle East is becoming more difficult to sustain, I think we would have expected to see a rise of, well, the Arab nationalism would take the form of energy nationalism. On the other hand, if we say, well, how in practice did OPEC come about. There was a very clear line, causal line sequence of events that run from the aftermath of Suez, the Western European turn to Soviet oil exports,
在价格上的话语权。现在我认为你可以争辩说，能源民族主义当时正在抬头，产油国中的能源民族主义，特别是在中东地区——因为你实际上可以追溯到1911年墨西哥及其墨西哥革命。随着大英帝国在中东越来越难以维持，我想我们会预料到这样一种情况的兴起，或者说阿拉伯民族主义将采取能源民族主义的形式。另一方面，如果我们探讨欧佩克实际上是如何诞生的，这里有一条非常清晰的因果脉络和事件发展顺序：从苏伊士运河事件的余波，西欧转向苏联石油出口，
the way in which the American, or the majors, I should say, the big seven, as they were then called, respond to that. And Venezuela's move to create OPEC. Yeah. And America then, because of this, gets drawn more and more to replace Britain. You've talked about how it's a tremendous strain on British foreign policy, that it has to kind of square its desire for both Arab and Israeli support. The other thing for which Britain is notorious in the Middle East,
以及美国——或者说各大石油巨头，当时被称为“七姐妹”——对此作出的反应，再到委内瑞拉采取行动创建欧佩克。是的。而美国此后由于这种情况，越来越被卷入其中以取代英国。你曾谈到这给英国外交政策带来了巨大的压力，因为它必须兼顾其对阿拉伯和以色列支持的双重愿望。英国在中东臭名昭著的另一件事，
certainly in Iran, is its readiness to meddle and pull strings and pull the carpet out from under governments. And America starts to, you know, if Britain kind of slowly becomes the little Satan, America steps in to become the great Satan. Do you think that essentially the problems that American foreign policy has faced in the Near East, they've inherited the foreign policy problems that the British had faced. And essentially it is oil that explains the existence of those problems.
尤其是在伊朗，就是它随时准备进行干预、暗中操纵并拆穿政府的台脚。而美国开始——你知道，如果说英国慢慢变成了“小撒旦”，那么美国就介入成为了“大撒旦”。你认为美国外交政策在近东面临的根本问题，其实是继承了英国曾经面临的外交政策问题吗？而且归根结底，正是石油解释了这些问题的存在。
Yes, but I put a big interlude in the middle of that, which is that when we get to 1971, when the British withdraw from east of Syria, they've made it clear a few years before that, that this is going to happen. The Americans are absolutely aghast at that. They regard it as a as a terrible um betrayal um and earlier in the decade so in the 60s when when johnson is i think it's about 1964 1965 he manages basically to make sure that
是的，但我要在其中插入一个重要的转折点，那就是当我们来到1971年，英国从苏伊士运河以东撤军时——他们在几年前就已经明确表示这将会发生。美国人对此感到无比震惊。他们认为这是一场可怕的背叛。而在本年代早期，也就是60年代，当约翰逊——我想大约在1964年或1965年——他基本上设法确保了
the the labour government gets some more financial help to prop up sterling to try to to avoid the the eventual outcome the decision that how Harold Wilson's government makes to withdraw from east of Suez. But given that this is happening in the late 60s, I think I'm pretty sure it's sometime after the Sterling devaluation. So either late 1967 or early 1968, when Wilson announces the withdrawal from east of Suez, the Americans are deep in Vietnam crisis at this point. So the idea that the united states could replace britain as the military power in the middle east that's supposed to do this work of providing energy security that's an that's an absolute non-starter and so the american um reaction uh by this point when nixon's in power is to, look, the British are gone. We don't want
工党政府获得更多财政援助来支撑英镑，试图避免最终的结果，也就是哈罗德·威尔逊政府做出自苏伊士运河以东撤军的决定。但鉴于这一切发生在60年代末，我非常确定那是在英镑贬值之后不久。所以要么是1967年末，要么是1968年初，当威尔逊宣布自苏伊士运河以东撤军时，美国人此时正深陷越南危机之中。因此，美国能够取代英国成为中东军事力量、承担起提供能源安全这一工作的想法，绝对是行不通的。所以美国的反应——当尼克松当权时到了这个阶段——就是：看吧，英国人已经走了。我们自己不想
to be there ourselves. So we're going to have to rely on the Saudis and we're going to have to rely on Iran. Well, that's kind of problematic on any number of levels, even at the beginning, not least because of the rivalry between Saudi Arabia and Iran. And obviously, the Shah thinks he can get all kinds of things for obliging the Americans in this respect. And the 70s, I think, then in this sense where the Middle East is concerned, can just be seen as a mess from the American point of view, because neither the Saudis or Iran, even before we get to the Iranian revolution, can do what they needed to do from the American point of view. And then when the Iranian revolution happens, things go, you know, just total disaster from the American position because now they're not only only left with the Saudis,
去那里。所以我们只能依赖沙特阿拉伯，我们只能依赖伊朗。嗯，这在任何层面上都有点问题，即使在一开始也是如此，其中一个主要原因就是沙特阿拉伯和伊朗之间的敌对关系。显然，沙特国王认为他为了在这方面取悦美国人，可以得到各种各样的东西。因此，从美国的角度来看，70年代的中东就可以被视为一团糟，因为无论是沙特还是伊朗——甚至在我们到达伊朗伊斯兰革命之前——都无法做到美国人需要他们做的事情。然后，当伊朗伊斯兰革命发生时，局势对美国立场来说简直是一场彻底的灾难，因为现在他们不仅只剩下沙特，
but they've actually got sanctions on Iran. So they're actually losing Iranian oil off the market. Then the Iran-I, Iraq war starts, which takes Iraqi, significantly reduces Iraqi oil production as well. is going to basically intervene if there's any external threat to American security interests, which mean energy security interests in the Middle East. It's not really very effective until we get to the first Gulf War. So actually, I would say that the story of the 70s and the 80s is when the British have gone, the Americans can't go there themselves, the proxies that they rely on are unreliable, including, it must be said, really using Iraq as a proxy in the 1980s during the course of the Iraq-Iran war. And it's only when the Soviet Union's been taken out of the picture, effectively, by the
而且他们实际上还对伊朗实施了制裁。因此他们实际上正在失去伊朗的石油供应。接着，两伊战争爆发了，这使得伊拉克的石油产量也大幅减少。美国将基本上进行干预，如果对美国的国家安全利益——也就是中东的能源安全利益——有任何外部威胁的话。在第一次海湾战争之前，这其实并不是很有效。所以实际上，我要说的是，70年代和80年代的故事是：当英国人离开后，美国人自己无法介入，他们依赖的代理人并不可靠——必须指出的是，这甚至包括在1980年代两伊战争期间真正将伊拉克作为代理人。只有当苏联通过
dissolution of the Soviet Empire in Eastern Europe in 1989, coming before the dissolution of the Soviet Union with the Gulf War, in the middle, that an American president is willing to commit American military power to the problem. Before we get on to the two Iraq wars, because I think they're really important in the story, and listeners will be keen to hear about them, just a quick note on the Soviet Union. So we did a series of podcasts about the dissolution of the Soviet Union
1989年东欧苏联帝国的解体而被有效地从画面中清除——在苏联解体之前伴随着海湾战争，处于中间阶段——一位美国总统才愿意将美国的军事力量投入到这个问题中。在我们讨论两次伊湾战争之前——因为我认为它们在故事中非常重要，听众也会热切地想要了解它们——先简单提一下苏联。所以我们做了一系列关于苏联解体
and the rise of Putin in Russia. And quite a lot of listeners were interested because we talked about oil and oil prices as a factor in the story of the Soviet kind of implosion in the 80s. So, Helen, do you think you think well here's another question from alfonso the 14th the pretender he's on fire isn't he yeah well i mean there's 16 more questions to go um so keep us going so he says is the soviet union the greatest victim of the oil resource curse um and i mentioned kapuscinski's you know lines at the beginning of the podcast
以及俄罗斯普京崛起的播客。相当多的听众对此很感兴趣，因为我们讨论了石油和油价作为苏联在80年代内乱故事中的一个因素。所以，海伦，你认为——这里有来自伪王阿方索十四世的另一个问题，他今天状态真火热，不是吗？是的，我的意思是还有16个问题呢，所以请继续——他说，苏联是石油资源诅咒的最大受害者吗？我提到了卡普钦斯基在播客开头的那些话，
so the soviet union basks under bre Brezhnev in this kind of complacency because oil prices are very high in the 70s. And then in the 80s, obviously, oil prices collapse. And their economy that's so dependent upon oil and gas then basically implodes. Gorbachev tries his reform program and it all goes wrong. Do you think that oil is the key factor in the collapse of this sort of Soviet
所以苏联在勃列日涅夫统治下沉浸在这种自满情绪中，因为70年代油价非常高。然后到了80年代，显而易见，油价崩盘了。他们如此依赖石油和天然气的经济随后基本上陷入崩溃。戈尔巴乔夫尝试了他的改革计划，结果一切都走向了错误的方向。你认为石油是导致这种苏联式实验崩溃的关键因素吗？
experiment? I think that this is a quite hard question to answer. I mean, I would fall back again on saying that if we look at the sequence of events as they happen, it's pretty important because it basically wrecks the finances of the Soviet state. And they're very quickly out of Afghanistan after the oil price crash. Because they're struggling financially, they need loans from, essentially, from like Western governments, Western banks, in order to be able to pay for the food import, their food import bill. So it brings a systemic crisis to the fore and basically means that Gorbachev has very few options you could argue that perhaps if he hadn't also been
我认为这个问题很难回答。我的意思是，我还是会回到之前的观点，如果我们看看事件发生的先后顺序，它是相当重要的，因为它基本上破坏了苏联国家的财政。在油价崩盘后，他们很快就撤出了阿富汗。由于他们财政困难，他们需要来自西方政府、西方银行的贷款，以便支付食品进口的账单。因此，它将系统性危机推到了前台，并基本上意味着戈尔巴乔夫几乎没有别的选择。你可以认为，如果他当时没有同时
trying to pursue the economic reforms he had at the same time it would have been easier but still it it it was I think a a massive blow and I think it's also true that if you look at the expansion of Soviet military power in the 70s and the ways in particularly their involvement in some African countries that actually well and I forget to stand for that matter that the conditions in which the Soviets engaged in military overstretch also had an oil underpinning from the oil boom of the 70s and the fact that the Soviet Union at that point was the world's largest oil producer. Indeed, it was still the world's largest oil producer when the oil price crash happened in 1986. So I was certainly prepared to say that I think that the Soviet Union would have lasted longer and that its crisis
试图推行经济改革，事情可能会更容易一些，但这仍然是一个巨大的打击。我认为这也是事实，如果你看看70年代苏联军事力量的扩张，特别是他们卷入一些非洲国家的方式——实际上还有阿富汗——苏联卷入军事过度扩张的条件，同样有着石油的支撑，这源于70年代的石油繁荣，以及当时苏联是世界上最大的石油生产国这一事实。事实上，当1986年油价崩盘时，它仍然是世界上最大的石油生产国。所以我当然准备好这样说：我认为苏联本来可以维持更长的时间，而且它的危机
wouldn't have been so sudden. I think that's the thing that really distinguishes the way that it happened in practice from the way that it possibly could have happened without the oil price crash. And I think the fact that it did happen in the way in which it did, so suddenly, both in Eastern Europe and then in 1991 with the disillusion of the Soviet Union, that was pretty consequential because it meant that this huge geopolitical change in europe and indeed in asia and central asia in in particular happened you know almost like with scarcely any consequence in in some sense not scarce any consequence for the people who were being liberated from soviet rule but i just mean in terms of the the the fact that it happened without without violence and I think that anything that would have been
也不会来得如此突然。我认为这正是实际发生的方式与如果没有油价崩盘可能发生的方式之间真正区别所在。而且我认为它确实以那种方式发生了，如此突然，无论是在东欧还是在1991年苏联解体时，这都产生了深远的影响，这意味着欧洲、甚至亚洲特别是中亚的这种巨大地缘政治变化，几乎可以说是毫无后果地发生了——在某种意义上，不是说对那些从苏联统治下解放出来的人没有后果，我的意思是就它发生时没有伴随暴力而言。我认为任何
a more protracted crisis of the Soviet Union would not have played out in that way. Although, of course, there's an argument that the violence was merely postponed. Well, that's what I'm saying. I think that there is, I mean, when we get onto the future, I think in that sense is the extraordinarily peacefulness of 89 and 91.
更加旷日持久的苏联危机都不会以那种方式收场。当然，也有观点认为暴力只是被推迟了。嗯，这就是我想说的。我的意思是，当我们谈到未来时，在某种意义上，89年和91年的异常和平，
In some sense, we're now living with the consequences of history having caught up with that as usual our attempts to sum up an enormously lengthy and complex topic in a single episode has failed so i think what we're going to have to do is we have to come back tomorrow for another episode with helen if that's okay with helen good it is um so uh and in that episode we'll look at more recent history so the gulf wars the north stream, current events in Ukraine, future of energy. I mean, so huge topics. And there is no one better to be discussing these topics with than Helen Thompson.
在某种意义上，我们现在正在承受历史追赶上来的后果。和往常一样，我们试图用单集节目来总结一个极其庞大且复杂的宏大主题失败了，所以我想我们明天得带着海伦回来再录一期节目，如果海伦不介意的话。太好了。那么，在那一期节目中，我们将探讨更近的历史：海湾战争、北溪管道、乌克兰的时事、能源的未来。我的意思是，这些都是巨大的主题。而且没有谁比海伦·汤普森更适合来探讨这些话题了。
So hopefully see you tomorrow. Until then, bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
希望我们明天见。在此之前，再见。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。如需获取独家单集节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，向你展示这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家单集节目以及提前获得现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。